[Music]
John Carpenter and Deborah Hills
Halloween celebrates its 40th
anniversary in 2018 and the occasions
being marked with a new movie harkening
back to the original film the movie will
ignore all other sequels in the series
there have been 10 Halloween's since
1978 including all the sequels remakes
and detours are they really all worth
ignoring to answer that question were
strolling methodically through Halloween
history like Michael Myers starting with
the outings were most ready to forget
Halloween for the return of Michael
Myers the greatest sin a movie can
commit is being boring and the return of
Michael Myers is just that picking up
ten years after the original return
finds Michael waking up from a
decade-long coma when he overhears he
has a niece it didn't get much more
thrilling from there we learned that
Laurie Strode has died in a car accident
leaving a young daughter Jamie with
nothing better to do
Michael meanders into town to find her
the return of Michael Myers promptly
turns into a tepid retread as Michael
begins robotically mowing down teenagers
with flat cinematography giving the
uninspired action nowhere to hide it's a
movie that coasts on its own concept
ultimately going nowhere
Halloween 2007 though Rob Zombie was a
bold choice to spearhead this reboot the
result is an over complicated unpleasant
mess mr. zombie has no small amount of
style and he assembles a solid cast for
his reimagine unfortunately the
relentless dreariness and unstable story
structure make it hard to connect with
half lengthy backstory half a remake of
Halloween one this interesting effort
just doesn't add up
Halloween the curse of michael myers.slc
lot revolves around the cult of thorn a
druidic
order bent on gaining power through
ritual sacrifice their leader is
revealed to be dr. Terrence Wynn a
character who appeared in one scene of
the first Halloween that you certainly
won't remember the tangled drama leaves
little room for either scares or fun the
moe
compelling reason to watch as to marvel
at Paul Rudd who seemingly doesn't age
Halloween resurrection the ape Halloween
begins as a reality TV satire with
contestants being sent into the old
Myers house for a knife the house is
full of spooky traps but the danger gets
real when Michael unexpectedly comes
home the first thing he kills is the
interesting concept
watching Busta Rhymes yell at a computer
is extremely fun but even he can't save
resurrection from being a dreary slog as
an added insult the film opens with a
convoluted retcon to undo the ending of
Halloween h2o which was originally
intended as a series finale as part of
this Jamie Lee Curtis appears in a sad
cameo being brought back as a resident
of a mental hospital only to die again
Halloween to 2009 mr. zombie returns to
write and direct a sequel to his remake
and it's a marked improvement over the
first attempt zombie chose to shoot
Halloween 2 on 16-millimeter film
lending it an authentically gritty
grindhouse feel that sets it apart from
more glossy horror movies it helps make
the movie a surreal hallucinatory feast
a unique turn for the series even if the
resulting movie is still not great
Halloween 5 the revenge of Michael Myers
what the fifth Halloween may lack and
originality it makes up for with fun
since her last encounter with the shape
Jamie has been experiencing
hallucinations that suggest some kind of
telepathic link with her uncle Michael
the movie is full of 80s era indulgence
but the real attraction is Donald
Pleasence as dr. Loomis the
long-suffering nemesis of Michael Myers
going more over the top than ever in a
single-minded efforts to stop the killer
for good he fails Halloween to 1981
Halloween to continues the story of
Halloween as directly as possible
working desperately all the while to
feel different the sequel also explains
Michael's relationship to Laurie
who's revealed to be his long-lost
sister the filmmakers knew that the
mystique of Michael could never be
recaptured only continued the sequel is
set entirely on the same night as its
predecessor letting Myers loose in a
hospital for an outing that's much more
gory and violent than the one that came
to
or but the movie never really justifies
its own existence setting a standard for
all the unnecessary follow-ups to come
Halloween h2o Halloween h2o is one of
the silliest titles in horror history
with the series seventh movie having
nothing to do with water instead the
title refers to the 20 years that have
passed since the first two Halloween's
took place it reveals Laurie Strode to
be alive again living under an assumed
name after faking her death serving his
headmistress of a private school
attended by her teenage son h2o is a
Halloween for the screen generation with
strong late 90's vibes in its casting
and style but while those traits have an
age that well the movie itself has being
a tight slick thriller that lets Laurie
fight back when Michael comes for her
son it's Jamie Lee Curtis who makes h2o
worth watching not only is her
performance as a haunted middle-aged
lorry compelling the story was also her
idea
with Curtis pitching it as being about
regaining the soul by facing your own
fear hey isn't that what the new one's
about to Halloween 3 season of the witch
the boldest Halloween sequel tried its
hardest not to be a Halloween sequel
convinced that more Michael Myers would
lead to diminishing returns original
writers carpenter and Hill decided to
transform the franchise into an
anthology with a third film telling a
new story about Halloween night the
story is about an Ancient Order of
warlocks who plan to slaughter children
on Halloween using the popular masks of
an evil novelty company
the masks powered by microchips
containing pieces of Stonehenge cause
bugs and snakes to explode from the
heads of their wearers when they're
triggered by a special TV commercial the
attack is vengeance for the
commercialization of Halloween meant to
usher in a new age of witchcraft
while that weirdness is refreshing the
movie itself isn't quite as bonkers as
it sounds but it's full of memorable
moments and could have set up a whole
new direction for the series
unfortunately it was rejected by both
viewers and critics and the anthology
concept was abandoned
Halloween 1978 we can debate the merits
of every Halloween sequel but the
original is in a class of its own
Halloween became legendary by perfectly
executing a simple concept
it's characters are ordinary and
relatable and there's no contrived
motivations or mythology there's just a
man in a mask waiting to kill you
the waiting is the key to Halloween's
power there are surprisingly few murders
in the film and the killings that do
occur are almost bloodless the movie
mines horror from Dredd not gore leaving
you breathless once the climax kicks in
add in the shadowy cinematography and
carpenters creepy keyboard score and
you've got a minimalist masterpiece that
redefined a genre